bonjour j'ai lu casanova merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
rt france vous êtes spécialiste en
communication pourquoi cette annonce
aujourd'hui près d'une semaine après le
preuve le deuxième tour des élections
municipales
est-ce que c'est pas ça parce qu'elle
les conseils municipaux dès ce week-end
pour élire les maires celui du havre
était prévue demain il aura lieu
finalement dimanche à 10 heures nous
sommes avec emmanuel macron en
permanence dans le spectacle la
communication c'est le choix qu'il a
faits à l'origine de gérer le pouvoir
politique de gérer sa carrière politique
de cette façon extraordinairement
spectaculaire cela fait des mois et des
mois que l'on parle du remplacement
d'edouard philippe donc on n'est pas du
tout dans le coup de tonnerre dans un
ciel serein
cela fait des mois que des noms
circulent à peu près toujours les mêmes
qui me présente guère de caractère de
nouveauté et en même temps ce matin on
annonce soudainement la démission du
premier ministre qui est en fête
traditionnelle après de grandes
sélections nationales mais contrairement
à l'habitude
le communiqué ne précise pas qui est
chargé de former le nouveau gouvernement
donc nous avons là un épisode organisé
de suspense suspension dramatique qui
permet aux nombreuses chaînes de
télévision dont on doit dire qu'elles ne
sont pas éloignés des vues de l'elysée
de se perdre en conjectures sur les
remarquables qualités de tout ce qui
pourrait venir et de celui qui va les
choisir met donc pour répondre
précisément à à ma question pourquoi
aujourd'hui cette cette annonce parce
qu'il devait y avoir un conseil des
ministres et que tenir un conseil des
ministres avec un premier ministre
partance
n'a pas beaucoup de sens donc l'annoncé
a été faite au moment où c'était d'un
point de vue technique le plus cohérent
et surtout cela laisse le temps pour
former le gouvernement d'aller jusqu'à
mercredi date du prochain conseil des
ministres
rien ne dit qu'il sera aisé est facile
de former un gouvernement même si ça
fait des mois qu'on y réfléchisse quant
au lieu où vous savez ces choses là se
font au dernier moment dans l'urgence
c'est là que se font les derniers
arbitrages et donc cette urgence elle
peut prendre des heures de nombreuses
heures de plus et savoir que le conseil
des ministres mercredi permet d'avoir
tout le week end pour négocier discuter
convaincre aussi parce que ce n'est
peut-être pas extraordinairement facile
pour emmanuel macron d'attirer des
personnes autour de lui dans une
situation qui s'annonce difficile et
avec un ou une premier ministre dont le
poids politique n'apparaîtra
probablement pas marquant puisque comme
souvent dans ces cas là pour la seconde
la dernière partie du quinquennat le
président veut un exécutant ou une
exécutante qui lui permettent d'être
directement premier ministre on a perçu
1 des images en direct de l'hôtel de
matignon
gilles casanova avec pour l'instant une
guerre de rapprocher un devants dans
cette cette porte pas de mouvement dont
on sait qu'il y à un tapis rouge qui a
été
déroulez qu'il ya des micros qui ont été
installées à l'intérieur derrière
derrière ces murs est ce que ça veut
dire que c'est imminent vous avez parlé
de d'une urgence d'un premier ministre
qui n'auraient pas forcément les coudées
franches mais qui pour justement succédé
à edouard philippe il ya beaucoup de
noms dernièrement parle de laurence
tubiana ou encore de bruno le maire
pourquoi pas pascal canfin comme l'a dit
kirill kotick of tout à l'heure à voir à
la fois un profil libéral progressiste
sociale et écologiste suite à la vague
verte du week-end dernier
est-ce que ça se trouve est ce qu est la
profondeur de banc nécessaire comme on
dit en football pour pour la république
en marche non ce qui est nécessaire ce
n'est pas ce dont vous avez fait la
liste ça c'est l'habillage qui sera
donnée ensuite et je peux vous assurer
que vos confrères trouveront que c'est
absolument merveilleusement réussi mais
ce qui est nécessaire c'est une personne
qui accepte d'être purement exécutante
et d'avoir le travail terrible des
nombreux arbitrages quotidien qui se
font à matignon de très nombreux
arbitrages quotidien et qui vont se
faire directement sous la férule de
l'elysée et donc il faut accepter une
position très inconfortable qui ne
permettra pas en retour d'avoir un
véritable pouvoir
donc il faut pour cela une personne
diaphane politiquement c'est à dire
quelqu'un qui ne soit pas un leader
politique quelqu'un qui est un profil de
haut fonctionnaire ou deux présentateurs
de télévision
je ne veux pas critiquer les
présentateurs de télévision n'est sûr
mais disons que ce ne sont pas des
personnalités politiques dont
l'orientation colère vous parlez d'un
exécutant à
gilles casanova pour ce poste de premier
ministre mais avec quelques apolitique
un remaniement c'est aussi un changement
de cap non à quoi est-ce qu'il faut
s'attendre en termes de politiques à
venir on a vu emmanuel macron s'exprimer
dans la presse quotidienne régionale ce
matin parler de la réforme des retraites
avec une nouvelle concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux tout en conservant
le projet il ya également l'écologie il
ya également le social ou encore le
ségur de la santé quel cap avec cette
femme qu'un canal comme vous le dites
pour cet exécutant selon sont en bo3
sémantique il n'a absolument aucune
intention de défier en rien du cap qu'il
a mis en oeuvre depuis trois ans si vous
l'écoutez avec attention
régulièrement il dit que plus rien ne
sera comme avant
puis il dit qu'il n'a en rien à renier
ce qu'il a fait depuis trois ans et que
ce qu'il va faire se place dans la
plaine continuité je crois que c'est la
deuxième partie de la phrase qui
comporte l'indication de ce qu'il va
faire la première partie
faisant partie de son habituelle
concession c'est à dire oui j'ai changé
je suis mieux en tous les cas cette
démission ce matin a suscité beaucoup
beaucoup d'émoi et des réactions de la
part la classe politique sur les réseaux
sociaux je vous propose de regarder ses
réactions en images
ils peuvent entièrement changé l'équipe
gouvernementale féminiser davantage
mettre des trouvailles baroque et cetera
mais puisque ils maintiennent la même
politique inégalitaire et
anti-écologique et veulent l'aggraver
les mêmes causes produiront les mêmes
effets je tiens à remercier edouard
philippe pour tout le travail qu'il a pu
accomplir comme premier ministre et je
lui souhaite un bon retour dans la ville
qui lui est si cher edouard philippe
démissionne pour un havre de paix vu ce
qui va arriver on comprend pour
l'instant les futurs prétendants font
peur schiappa taubira belloubet s'il
s'agit pour emmanuel macron de nous
dégoter un premier ministre qui met en
oeuvre la même politique libérale et
valide la réforme des retraites contre
laquelle les français se sont battus
pendant des mois
c'est pas la peine de faire
tant de bruit un faux suspense et sur le
changement de casting qui n'aura aucune
incidence avec la poursuite d'une
politique anti écolo et sociales
dépeçage de l'ambition de la convention
citoyenne réforme des retraites
ce remaniement fait du prince symbole
d'une vème république à bout de souffle
fier des 1140 saint geours d'edouard
philippe à matignon et merci à emmanuel
macron de lui avoir fait confiance
gilles casanova comment est-ce que vous
réagissez à toutes ses déclarations sur
les réseaux sociaux avec cette démission
eh bien vous voyez que d'un côté on
s'enthousiasme pour et loire philippe et
de l'autre côté on n'attend guère de
changement dans la politique du
président les français d'ailleurs sont
de cet avis les trois ou quatre
dernières études d'opinion demandant si
on s'attendait à ce que le président
modifie sa politique dans notre 65 et
70% des français qui pensent qu emmanuel
macron ne change rien ne changera en
rien son orientation politique
on s'attend donc à skis emmanuel macron
face d'eux les manuels macron et le
premier ministre se fera donc discret
merci j'ai casanova d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
consultant expert en stratégie en
communication passer par de nombreux
ministères